this is a very interesting topic i found
the study
that demonstrated that you could
actually reduce your liver fat
by almost 50
in just two
weeks
and i'm not kidding this is not a joke
this is a credible study there's a
14-day intervention study putting people
on a carbohydrate restrictive diet this
is called the ketogenic diet
where they consumed less than 30 grams
of carbohydrates per day and this
demonstrated decreased liver fat by
43.8 percent so it's not actually 50 but
it's close in subjects with obesity and
what is that
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
now there are several other interesting
things about this number one there
wasn't much weight loss on average there
was only like a 1.8 percent
weight loss
which is pretty insignificant
and there is no change
in waist
circumference now this is very good
information to know because if you
started a ketogenic diet and you lost
hardly any weight the first week
and there's no change in your waste you
might just quit and think it's not
working apparently the body gets rid of
liver fat and organ fat
as a priority before it goes after other
types of fat and apparently the loss of
liver fat was due to decreased something
called d noble lipogenesis what is that
that means there's a greatly reduced
conversion from carbohydrates
to fat there's like a 79.8 percent
decrease so no longer are we getting
this conversion from carbohydrates
to fat and there was also an increase in
actual overall fat burning called fatty
acid oxidation by just under 5x so we
had this five times greater
fat oxidation or fat burning effect in
the liver amazing now there's some also
very interesting additional things on
this study
first of all the participants did not
lower their calories the average amount
of calories per day was over three
thousand
so this was not a globe calorie diet
there was also significant lower markers
for liver damage
significant lower fasting insulin levels
and lowered homa ir which means there
was less insulin resistance there was
improved insulin sensitivity there was
lower liver inflammation and
there was a rapid increase
in folate producing bacteria and folate
in their blood so apparently in the
ketogenic diet your microbes make more
folate now what is up with this folate
what does the folate do in relationship
to your liver well it improves liver fat
metabolism and it keeps liver
inflammation
on the low side and they found 94
bacterial strains
were altered after going on this low
carb diet with major shifts in microbes
occurring just in one
day if you're new to my channel or
you're not new you've been watching my
videos and you haven't started ketogenic
diet
i think this right here is a good enough
reason to get started
right away so i put a link down below
the exact version of the ketogenic diet
you need to start immediately check it
out
hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content
i would love to hear about your success
story
please share it in the link down below